they don't come down on its own listen
I'm using the chopsticks per quince
request hopefully I don't pick on number
two today throwing around ideas at the
beginning of the year one of the ones
that came up was Clint's experience with
a pair of chopsticks I was in a Korean
restaurant you read the back of the
chopsticks and in step three is you can
pick up anything now anything
me and Sam took it as far as we could
take it busted out this beautiful v1
here and what we're gonna do now is talk
about that v1 then we make the video who
you thinking about casting for this
myself is the chopstick guy yeah there's
like one role or did you want to be a
well I really want to be start being in
more quarters unless I'm super good with
chopsticks like you're making a video
about chopsticks you should probably
have somebody that that's pretty good
for chops I'm good
hey I caught a fly with chopsticks once
if you think you're really good with
chopsticks I'm super good with
chopsticks then I challenge you to go a
full day with just using chopsticks as
your hands I'm doing this you're gonna
give 24 hours man all right bathroom and
all I can do this now I know you got it
you gotta do that and you'll put me in
the video yeah I'll put you in the video
I'll put you I'll put you in the video
all right did you guys know today's the
day what's the day today is the day
where I prove to Clint and everyone else
in the studio that I'm the man for the
job I am going to go all day with just
chop stick hands and Jake catch look it
there I'll get there right now so I
don't know if I'm gonna your phone's
ringing
oh no no I missed the call yeah hold on
yes
hey Nico hey Jake hey how you doing good
hey uh you know that you got chopsticks
or fingers and I'm a little worried
about it impacting your performance here
at corridor are you fulfill all your
duties that we expect of you yeah of
course why would I wouldn't do this if I
felt otherwise I have full faith and
confidence in my ability to get work
done today okay
you think it's golden here Christian
yeah I'm vibrating that's gonna be worst
thing about if I if I have a broken one
what is gonna happen I have to go to the
bathroom he pulls splinters out of your
butt
Dave they're still there Hey look it'll
come down on its own
[Music]
it's not so bad I'm gonna make a lunch
these are already on here so tight this
thing
I think eating was gonna be the easiest
part of the day this part is easy to use
your left hand gotta practice that
actually kind of I didn't think this
through very well
first thing that happens when I get home
every night my daughter runs up to me
and wants me to pick her out look at how
good dirty and grimy these are our a
well hopefully I don't have to go number
two today finish my lunch I was walking
upstairs I had the thing right here
[Music]
you're not the man in the arena okay I'm
the one with the chopsticks okay you
can't just take chopsticks your hands
and then use your hands an appointment
you have to use the chopsticks to sweep
that's the challenge all right how am I
gonna eat again though fine fine I'll do
it
you know why click I know why you would
be in this you want to be in the video
I'm gonna be in this video it's the man
I'm here man
[Music]
listen I'm using the chopsticks per
Clint's request but does this count yes
okay thank you
thank you how do you say who's
left-handed somebody is why it's done
that dad
[Music]
hey man hey man I'm just working you
know I'm running the bear if you want to
go yeah I had an idea you should shoot
it under the supermarket and I hold them
up to stick up okay yeah there's
something different about you man I
can't I can't quite put my finger on it
what do you think it is
hey do you like my joke I just made
about the chopstick fingers your hoodie
pocket I just need my cash so do that
actually
[Music]
but a Knick can you put the give me more
tape on my fingers I seem to be slipping
out and I want to make sure that I stick
to this to stick to my word to Clint all
day hey man how you doing let me get a
raincoat
[Music]
I'm moving sales here we go check it out
yeah let's do it
good yeah literally garage sales are
like my favorite thing huh my socks are
wet I'm thinking we need a boat to get
down the street now
they can smell the garage sale what's
all for sale here everything this
cyclopædia yeah I'm into this ax and
this book I'm going to go through well I
only have $21 on me I'd buy the book in
the axe for $21 what is this
it's an encyclopedia of modern
architecture I got a little library at
home so for $21 you want the ax in the
book yeah maybe challenge him to get to
a certain page with okay all right give
birth to a whole new way to get through
books here we go nineteen oh it's like
crisis right it's like prices right yeah
they're like stuck together only the
power of chopsticks can you get through
this oh I did it
wow this is a really good buy for you
and the boy how you gonna pay for the
water beats it I might pick up some more
of these are we still gonna go get water
hmm
are we still gonna go get water I think
we should I'm out of money though would
you like to know how well the water trip
went what what happened I think they
lose ax for 20 bucks though they're
selling chairs for ten bucks a pop are
you talking about the unit B thing they
got some good
we're back dude well that was extremely
inconvenient but Clint's gonna put me in
the video and I got my club soda right
in front of me here so there's only one
thing left to do
sit back open it up and enjoy it I'm
thinking thinking about our patreon
supporters they got some really cool
skills like Phillip Oxford thermal
management master got master one ace won
the second runner-up pilot in the world
Air Force of London we got Gary Dolph
who is the second cousin to Gandalf
there's not very many wizards in the
world there's like five but he's like a
half wizards so he doesn't really count
as a full wizard but I thank you for
your support
Nicholas Psaltis is a shark whisperer he
knows how to talk to any shark and make
them chew on all kinds of minced meat
that is not him G squared who if you
didn't know is actually a giant because
he ignores the square cube law and is
big Taylor Dunbar who holds the world
record for doing the most number of
push-ups and pull-ups at the exact same
time not a Canadian spy who is amazing
because he's not a spy we take for
granted how great it is that most people
are not spies Mitch Polinski who I've
never seen hold so many tools in his
belt as he runs to first base in 1938 at
the World Series premiere of that
American Life what I know right that's
amazing Mitch dude
although he did drop the hammer rounding
two-second glitch cube who is the most
flawless sphere of all time James Bailey
who has the best eye for a big artwork
and he also was the first guy to ever
eat at polar bear and finally we have
Bryan and toesik
who was the first person to ever come up
with a very special polymer that can go
through a glue gun and some say that
that was the result that ended the
Berlin wall
Thank You Bryan
figure though thank you so much to all
of our patreon supporters we couldn't do
any of this without all of you and I
really appreciate all of the jobs that
you have in life thank you so much for
bringing joy to me I hope you enjoy your
lore and if you want to sign up and get
your own lore okay check out
patreon.com/crashcourse or digital where
you going man where you going
[Music]